okay why don't we
go ahead and get started uh thank you
everyone for
coming um we we usually only have
one talk per week but whenever we have
a luminary in town um and that would be
our speaker today not me yesterday we
will move the conference to a different
time of the week so um
i i'm really delighted to uh introduce
andre kushnick
who is actually not too far away from us
up at the university of victoria where
he's a professor in the
school of health information science he
was previously director of the school
and then
has has gone back to pursuing more
purely academic pursuits and he truly is
a world renowned
expert in usability applied to
health information systems and most of
his work has focused on that but i was
actually delighted when he told me he's
doing some work in whole exome
sequencing and usability
which i think brings in
spans the whole program and not just
focused on
clinical informatics just by background
he
received bachelor's degrees in biology
and psychology from brock university
masters in computer science from
mcmaster university and then a
phd in cognitive psychology from mcgill
university and he's been very active in
many aspects of
informatics in canada and
like i said is is known around the world
so um i will let andre present his
okay i'm really happy to be here it's
actually the first time i've been to the
department i've been to portland once
before but
really happy to be here um so my
presentation is
improving the usability of health
information systems from
uh rapid usability testing and i'll talk
about that
to what we're calling clinical
simulations so i'm going to talk about
a little bit of history at least the
projects we've worked in from actually
the very first project i worked on to
the
some of the more recent ones including
the one that bill mentioned that
beginning is beginning to bridge into
bioinformatics
so we all know the potential of health
care systems electronic health records
systems personal health records decision
support tools
educational systems patient information
systems and
and mobile and handheld applications and
but we also know
that there's been a lot of issues with
all these areas and over
the past while we've actually done
usability projects on
every category here because there was
such such a demand for
for some improvements and we'll talk
about that
i would like to just begin where i'm
coming from from the area of human
computer interaction
and uh the challenges in healthcare
perhaps
the hardest challenges for human
computer interaction than in any other
domain
even more so than in any business domain
i've also did a bit of a stint
and nuclear power and even in that area
it wasn't as complex
it seems like from a human point of view
as what we're looking at
so the point at the bottom is if and
we'll look at a human computer
interaction taken very broadly
if you take a broad definition of human
computer interaction
it may well be the single most important
barrier to successful implementation of
systems in health care
talking to bill this morning about
developments around the world there's a
lot of technical developments in some
countries that allow people
to interconnect patient data nationally
citizens can access it
but there's a lot of issues around human
aspects and i like to also talk about
human aspects as a broad topic
that are preventing that from happening
so from my perspective the solution was
always
go outside of health informatics and
apply
information and ideas from other areas
and the two areas
i've sort of come from is human computer
interaction hci
and the other one i'll talk a lot about
today's usability engineering
uh engine approaches to engineering
software that sort of came out of
early 1990s in california silicon valley
those areas and trying to bring them
i've been trying to bring them into
health care ever since
and extend the methods and we'll look at
it across the board from system design
not only system design but
system implementation system
customization
training and even system selection so
whether or not you're designing or
building a system or working with a
commercial system
it cuts across so i'll introduce what i
call low-cost usability engineering
methods that can be employed for
developing more
usable and useful healthcare systems
another distinction we like to look at
is
usable is easy to use but it's no good
unless it's also useful the content has
to be relevant
for healthcare professionals so those
are two dimensions sometimes
the useful part gets lost in some
engineering labs
um and i want to look at the how we
measure impact of healthcare i.t
on work and workflow because that's also
becoming another issue over the years
how do we
uh there's issues with impact and
workflow what are practical ways for
looking at that
at least show our perspective is only
one so
hci or human computer interaction
involves obviously the study of end
users and their interaction
with computers and we'll see we can look
at hci at multiple levels from the level
of the individual user with the system
to the individual user doing a work task
perhaps interviewing a patient
to group or collaborative activities so
we'll also look at individuals and
groups
and uh basically we want to do this to
improve
systems and my definition i like of hci
is a very broad one
that fits with a lot of work from bill
and joan and that is that human computer
interaction hci is a discipline
concerned with design
evaluation and implementation of
interactive computing systems for human
use
and with the study of major phenomena
surrounding them so as i can
say at the beginning i said i think it's
maybe the single most important factor
in health informatics that's because i'm
taking a very broad perspective
emerging from areas like computer
science psychology
many others but i'll zero in on what i
mostly work in is the area i i consider
the subfield of hci or human factors
usability and usability uh before we
used to talk about
user friendliness that wasn't really
defined well usability is a good term
because it's had
definitions come up and one of my
favorite definitions was actually from
1993
by priests and there are a number of
dimensions
of usability or ease of use of a system
uh one is learning uh
how easy is it to use to learn how to
use a system learnability we could spin
off another term
effectiveness is the system does the
system do what it's supposed to
if you're going to enter medications
does it do it properly
but also efficiency does it take 20
steps when it only should take three
enjoyability or lock up and the reason
why i like the priest definition is
because
at the beginning she included safety um
and safety got lost from the definition
i think the if you look up the um
standard definition now from standards
organization has international standards
organization i'm
not sure if they included it again but
where i'm coming from was this idea of
usability
engineering as being a set of scientific
approaches that can be brought to bear
in health care
so let's drill down and say what are the
main approaches you'll see how we
started with these and modified them
well the first one is actually a very
simple idea usability testing
it's observing representative users
doing representative tasks
uh we might ask them to do something
i'll give an example
of a think aloud protocol where you ask
them to think about using the computer
and we might video record them so the
concept is very simple if you were
developing a lot of consultants in
usability
if you're developing a word processing
system for secretaries you'd have
secretaries come in 10 of them
do word processing tests in our studies
we'll have 10 or so
or 20 physicians come in our nurses come
in doing order entry tasks or decision
support tasks using a system
uh on video recording i'll get into how
we do that
uh the next uh level we'll talk about is
called clinical simulations
and this is where we we gave a different
title to it because it's representative
users
doing representative tasks i could have
someone sit here and do a usability test
but if i actually have them do it in
their real environment in an operating
room or in a
hospital ward we're calling those
clinical simulations
and they don't have to be in a
simulation lab and we'll also argue you
can do that
low cost and high fidelity by taking the
study into the into the
organization and i won't mention much
about this one but this one is also very
useful usability inspection
where you the analyst step through and
analyze an interface
as opposed to watching users and we've
used this on many projects
in conjunction with the other two
methods it's a predictive methodology
you always still need to watch the users
so
you can ask when when can usability
studies take place
when i started i it was at the end of
the and we'll see an example the very
first project it was too late to help
the project
was after the project was released we
can do studies to
test if the system is doing what it's
supposed to in the real situation
we can also i might mention if i have
time something called the virtual
usability lab where we can track people
using systems over the internet
those are all at the end of the life
cycle over time we started moving back
working with different organizations to
try to
to work with usability during
implementation uh and that's when
clinical simulations became very useful
because it's near live and
i'll give an example of a near live
study just before you go live catching
those last glitches
moving back into design you can do
usability testing and inspection methods
and even if you go back as far as
analysis i teach in my courses do early
mock-ups of anything you're going to
develop and and have a think-aloud study
of people using them
and even you can go back to planning
stages as talking to bill this morning
even if you're buying a commercial
system and you're planning and you're
going to buy a commercial system
we're now proposing that uh most
requests for proposals include
uh of the requirement that all the
candidate systems be installed in the
hospital to be tested head-on using
usability methods
so if someone asks when can you use this
it's not just for if you're the designer
of a system in a company it's across the
entire spectrum
so that what i call low-cost rapid
usability testing uh
that it doesn't require an expensive
fixed usability lab
there's reasons for using those but for
in many cases you don't need it
and the other argument is if you're
testing systems you need to also test
them locally
if i have a conformance testing lab or
usability lab in
toronto or chicago and says x product
works and i bring it to my hospital
there's no guarantee it'll work
in my hospital with all the interfacing
technologies so what we're saying is we
still need centralized testing but we
also need
low cost efficient ways to ensure
systems are safe in our local
environment
and when i present this sometimes people
say it's low cost therefore it's low
fidelity
not realistic my argument's always been
if you can
test the system in the real environment
off hours we routinely do this on
projects around the world is the highest
level of fidelity
because you don't have to try to
recreate the scenario interfacing
technology
say bar coding and can be applied you
can either
use the laboratory approach but also we
say we'll see
this uh moving it towards what we call
clinical simulations
so what's the equipment well normally i
use the cheapest possible equipment
so there's no barrier with any
organization on my computer
or a laptop i'm running it i'll use a
free software i often use something
called hypercam
which just records what you're doing on
the computer as a movie file
and if you turn audio on it records the
audio so right away in media player
you can play back that's my date unit of
data that i pass around
on projects in different countries they
send me that in fedex's
uh so you can record everything i'm
saying or doing on a computer
using this recording software it even
allows you if if you're locked down
to run it off a flash drive and store it
on the movies on another
and i'll just put i put an external
camera here to say sometimes you need
the external view as well
and normally we never need more than
about one because if i'm doing a study
of how someone's using a system in the
office
i may want to know what they're doing on
the computer and also if they're using
papers or moving anything on the desk
so often two views is all that you need
and in some of our studies we literally
had
if it was a simulation study uh uh a
camera on a tripod
uh with the hypercam running on one or
more workstations
um if it's a live situation we might
have that a ceiling mounted camera but
that's just me thinking aloud using the
think allowed method from psychology
while i'm using a personal health record
it's the the movie's being stored on
here with the audio and i also have an
external view of what i'm doing on the
desk
simple as possible laboratory style
usability test
the data is very clear you can play it
back and see exactly what you're
clicking on which is one of the
arguments why you don't necessarily have
to have
a million dollar lab with the one-way
mirrors to watch people using systems
uh the other sort of framework and uh
organize the talk around this
as i mentioned then this sort of
triangle i think we used a triangle
because things become
uh less constrained as you go up this
ladder at the bottom
and this sort of came out of work we did
in consulting in that as well
is that the simplest way to start
looking at a system if there's a problem
in an organization is what i call level
one
the system you the user using the system
in isolation of anything else
and we can set up a usability test very
simply to look at that level
and in some of the studies um i remember
one
project i did in new york that no one
could use the electronic record system
nobody could tell you why but when i had
them think aloud using it half the time
when the cursor blinked because i had
the movie file you could see that you
could enter data
half the time you couldn't so we coded
about 200 consistency problems
fixed it it was easy fixed not all fixes
are easy went up to the next level to
see how they used it in practice
no problem that was lucky but the idea
was if you start here you can start
identifying the surface level problems
fix those and then move up a lot
a level and i'll talk about moving up to
the work task level shortly but i'll
just give an example
of and this also mirrors what we did in
our studies historically starting from
here moving up this ladder
to more complex situations but and i'll
talk about later how we're packaging
it as a multi-layer approach but in the
beginning we just started working
at simple studies somebody sitting down
using a system
so the very first one i that we
published actually was in 1995
and it was for a cd that was going to be
given on this little cdi player that
would plug in a tv set i don't
remember those and it was going to be
sent to doctors with no instructions so
at mcgill we just set up a room and had
four positions try it and four medical
students
um and we video recorded their
interactions with the system
uh back then you had to use like a pc to
video converter it's a lot simpler now
with the digital movie recording
and we had people think aloud and
capture the screens
but even then we were beginning to look
at how do you analyze that type of data
so we started
using coding schemes and i will note
that you can use computer supported
video coding back then we used a
simple program called c video which was
a hundred dollar program that ran on a
mac
sc that would connect to a vcr and you
could annotate your movie files with it
so we opened up text in that button
uh there's many tools that are free
transana but actually you don't even
need to use a tool you could have one
file open
on a text file on a computer and watch
the video on the other mark it up
but coding the data was very important
how do we analyze or look at the data so
we brought in the ideas from human
computer interaction
for analyzing data so we developed
categories and again this was sort of
modified from
doing video analysis in psychology
studies
where you come up with a dictionary a
coding dictionary of things you might
look for
this was our very first one and since
we've modified it for many different
projects
you have categories like content is
there an indication that there's too
much information too little
is information out of date is it not up
to relevant
comprehension can the user comprehend
graphics or text
navigation i'll show you how we use the
coding codings we still use the same
approach
his ability to move forward or backward
is the user lost somewhere on the screen
user control can they control the pace
system understandability can you
understand the icons
and even you can code for if the system
crashes which was interesting because in
many studies the system crashed and the
system logs that it didn't crash
but what happened when we watched the
interaction was sometimes it didn't
buffer returns and it just accidentally
exited so we can also the coding schemes
that we had were open-ended so why not
also look at other aspects including
cognitive aspects like reasoning
if i'm asking someone to think aloud
about a system they may be thinking
aloud
i have a problem with closing the window
but i also think the patient has
diabetes so
i'll show how we use studies where we've
also coded for
what they're thinking about in terms of
hypotheses
in terms of studies that i'll mention
where we have had
recordings of people using systems while
talking to a patient or simulated
patient
they're not thinking aloud so we're
recording the interaction so we can
record what requests for information
they
they have of a patient in the interview
and relate that to the computer screen
and
i'll show you an example of how you can
look at how the screen changes the
the interview you can also do things
like of course
uh contr analyze mouse clicks and things
often we don't go to that level
but this was our log file this
corresponded to the video
of that very first user that we had and
it was for
when it was done was 19 we did the study
in 1992
and you'll see that they're mentioning
as you're reading this that
they think the information's too old it
was set on it was 1988 apparently all
the guidelines had changed in 1990.
so everyone was sensitive to that uh at
first the user says i've had to loosen
my tie if i had the video it's quite
funny and you can click on the number it
goes right to the
the part where he's just sitting here
i'm recording him and says my first
comment is 88 is old i don't know if
anything has been updated
so we're very interested again not just
usability but usefulness this was a
usefulness category
you can watch as the user goes through
the different parts of the system it had
a decision support component
it clicks on different cholesterol
levels and then gets stuck
on the video i have it if it wants to
see after i digitized it how do i fast
forward
so that's an example of a navigation
problem that comes from our dictionary
where we define navigation problem and
we can even do things like integrated
reliability and have two coders do it
and come up with a kappa coefficient we
only do that for publishing usually
but this is nice because we can code for
different issues that are usable issues
usability issues so we can say for
example uh 80 percent of the users that
use module 1 of this
ehr had this many an average of so many
navigation problems it
focuses you and and when you take it
back to the developers you can go right
to the video section and show them where
this occurs
uh there's no way out of this and then
the system actually crashed
this was a system that was going to be
released widely so that's after that
project we decided to always work
earlier in the design cycle because it
was too late
and then things have changed a lot i'd
probably turn it off
and then he can't find the options menu
on the help bar
it didn't come with instructions
literally didn't it was supposed to be
easy to use
and now he facetiously says i have to
get out the owner's manual
so i mean this was 1992 but
unfortunately we watch users using
healthcare information systems today
and i've seen lots of examples that are
still in league with this one
in terms of of issues and at the time we
were also interested in
what the normal way of people were
assessing usability
and you know i was talking to bill a lot
of times people say they're doing
usability but maybe they had a focus
group or they gave out a questionnaire
and questionnaires are useful we use
them a lot on wide scale studies
to thousands of users but for these
small scale detail studies
this is what that user actually said i
found the program easy to use
and there's a five or seven point scale
we just put the answers he agreed
somewhat fairly easy to learn agreed
somewhat
the content of the program is presented
clearly well agreed uh completely agreed
uh completely but we never thought to
ask uh uh
was the content out of date so it was
emerge an emergent issue
and an inadvertent consequence of the
system uh that you needed the video to
watch so what we tended to do
is after we have someone do a task just
keep the audio recording on and have a
semi-structured interview
we asked them did you just have problems
now using the system
and when you do that you end up having
something that corroborates your video
usually or enhances it
and then studies where you can't
actually have somebody thinking aloud
like you're looking at someone
doing an operation you're looking at the
operating room system
then you can do elizabeth's done this as
well post cued recall where you play the
video back to them and you record the
interaction
so that was our very first study and
then we got interested in cognitive
aspects of usability
what was the impact of systems on a
reasoning individual decision making
group decision making and
technology induced errors inadvertent
introduction of errors
and we wanted to look at how that could
be integrated into usability so many of
the other studies
are pure usability we've done but many
are also dealing with
uh also looking at the impact of
usability on
on work performance and decision making
so that's i just put in this organizer
level two the user interacting with the
system and their environment to carry
out a work task
and our first experiments in that was
looking at the user
using the computer system interviewing a
patient so now we've moved from the
individual uh
situation to more like a distributed
cognition situation
and this is where we started using the
term simulation uh
clinical simulation uh for analyzing
impact on workflow and i'll show
different
type of analysis that was a series of
papers that were actually done
at mcgill the first one we had was from
md computing in 96 and then there was a
jmap paper in 2001
where we had a whole clinic that was
going from paper records to electronic
we actually had some going back to paper
just to see what would happen uh and we
were looking at uh matched records for
learning styles and direct observation
of the process of them learning how to
use and adopt the system
so in one of the case we had the classic
level one think aloud where we had them
think aloud using the system
uh and this was interesting because then
we said uh the
company that had made the product wanted
to know how the system was used when the
patient was there
no one had looked at this so we borrowed
from the
and i guess you have that here the
simulated patient standardized patient
paradigm
just put the computer in the middle so
what we're recording now is the computer
screens and the dialogues it becomes a
different type
of it's dialog analysis and we also had
uh
set up so that we watch the progression
from a person
interviewing a standardized patient with
no computer and then the introduction of
the computer and over time to see how
they adapted
and you could see definite styles and we
also won't get into looked at
people entering on paper asking to put
in the computer exactly and vice versa
uh so that was the system and it was an
interesting idea at the time it was
something called the
paper scroll metaphor you scroll along
here and you click on categories here
so if someone came in with a cough you'd
load a cough a template and then
what happened with this system and just
jumping ahead is that
it had an impact because uh there wasn't
really an easy way to search the page
for where you wanted to go
in your your own head so if you walked
in
early to a template there was no global
search
um and so people would just start asking
questions in the order on the screen
or say i'm not going to use the system
at all so on the video was the first
thing we're watching late at night the
videos we see
people that walked away from it got
bogged down on the screen and other
people said i get the idea now and just
started asking
filling out on this order so it wasn't
to say all systems did that but it was
to say
that systems could uh have a profound
impact on the interview
the other part that was interesting was
when we did the experiment where we
asked them to enter
some their cases in here and also on
paper
and also counterbalanced it that there
was about 25 percent less information in
here and there was a different emphasis
of
information and when we looked at
information items and the reason was is
that some of these categories
on the computer screen were more or less
developed so if you had more sub
categories under this tab
more information would be presented or
less so it was a again another example
of
how the system uh even what information
is on the screen might impact what's
recorded in the system
uh so this just summarizes we
interviewed uh 16 clinical staff did
usability testing
this was our first time we also looked
at training i mentioned to bill on some
of our projects
uh what we've been doing is going in and
looking at the training
we did this on on a rollout of a system
in new york
looked at the actual training for the
vendor system to find out what they were
taught
and then uh did usability test months
two months later to kind of get a
learning curve on it and when something
was missing we could go back to the
training and see whether
uh there was an important piece there
with this particular system the
the most predictive thing of adoption
was actually did they get far enough in
the training
to learn how to re-customize the
interface but most of them had dropped
out before then
so it was really interesting because you
could log all the system use over time
and they didn't have to adopt the system
so it was one of those studies where you
could say
we're looking at people's real choice of
adopting or not
and i just mentioned that already for
corresponding records they
generally contain less information items
and change in reasoning so we said
before when they were interviewing the
patients they were hypothesis driven
the standardized patients they were
going where they wanted in their own
knowledge base
whereas with this system they tended to
drop into a screen driven behavior
and that we were relating at the time to
medical reasoning saying that the more
expert
expert-like reasoning is from pieces of
patient data uh
generating multiple hypotheses we call
forward driven
and uh less expert or when you're
learning is more backward driven you
have a diagnostic hypothesis looking
backwards to the
conditions so it was interesting that in
some cases it seemed that the system
until they adapted to it
uh brought some expert uh physicians
more down to
this level and then they learned how to
adapt to it or it didn't adopt it
and the way the actual um and you'll see
how this related to later work the
the granularity of the coding is
different now we're not looking at the
this is a log file the individual
thinking aloud uh but on the video we
mark it up and and
first two minutes they go and create a
patient visit when they're interviewing
the patient
uh gather information this was an
experienced user
was gonna start to use the system after
three minutes but then decides to
continue writing on paper
eventually after nine minutes chooses a
clinical template goes into the
system and follows the screens so when
we interviewed him he said he realized
this was after six months of use
how the system was useful and guiding
you but you needed to not be triggered
too early to go into the system
so that's uh where we got there now what
we've got to more recently is level
three
uh looking at moving it uh into
more and more real uh situations and
having studies that actually
take advantage of the different levels
and just before i get into there we can
say just on a continuum of studies
if i have someone in a laboratory or
sitting down here doing artificial tasks
like entering
from paper into an ehr which is a good
task for picking up
surface problems we call that laboratory
style that would include the think aloud
method
the simulations that i talked about are
simulated doctor patient interviews or
clinical simulations are kind of in the
middle they stimulate workflow
and then you can also uh go into the
naturalistic setting in the real setting
and also run simulations there
we call those i don't have it in there
in situ simulations
but you can also study uh the real thing
so in many of our projects we set the
recording equipment up in the location
and assuming they have irb approval
we can do a prediction on a simulation
and then see what happens when the
recording goes
live so uh level three for error
identification prediction and mitigation
uh it's another check
before systems released widely as i
mentioned before
system is released across a hospital say
what's the impact on workflow
so argument was just extending the
approaches need for low-cost portable
approaches for conducting simulations in
emergency rooms icu
or hospital wards so this is an example
this was a recent study 2012 that we did
with um
um it was at uh with mount sinai it's
joseph cannery
and that uh tom mcginn and uh
devin mann i don't know if you know them
it was an itch international journal
medical informatics it's a
series of studies that included all
three levels so we kind of moved to
packaging it this way
the study employed several phases we had
a level one
where we had a bit about the tool it was
called icpr
decision support tool was a um
evidence-based guidelines to be
incorporated into a major vendor product
in in the hospital and uh we were
looking at how to increase the actual
adoption of guidelines at the end of the
day
there was actually a clinical controlled
trial but we wanted to see how usability
could be applied so we said let's look
at this for multiple levels
we'll do a level one analysis a surface
level usability testing eight clinicians
came in
and we kind of drove them through the
system so they were forced to go through
different parts of the system so it
wasn't exactly a think aloud
it was like here's a scenario now what
would you click on on the screen
and think aloud the second was a
clinical simulation
where we didn't have a human patient we
wanted to see how the guidelines would
be triggered in their workflow so we had
a digital patient
on the computer screen so they could ask
for information in the order they wanted
the first one forced them through a
certain way
and the third one was we did some
limited uh studies of recording live
interactions
uh with the use of the guidelines this
was a bit trickier because
how do you get the thing to trigger just
for those cases where the guidelines are
needed in the real situation
it was an experiment we were doing all
three but the first two definitely
were were more successful the first one
i can just say some examples and you'll
see in a minute
the first thing that came up when we did
the testing was one of the screens
should have triggered a guideline and a
window came up with an acronym bp uh bpa
on it
and we know what bpa is
ah yeah uh yes the best practice to look
but where we were testing it
nobody knew what it was so no one
clicked on it so on the surface level
usability test we was a little bit more
interaction than that we said why didn't
you click on and say well i don't know
what is why would i click on it
so it wasn't very obvious i think we had
them put you know
some written out text or make it more
clear that wasn't a surface level issue
that would have prevented people from
using it
so we we check marked a lot of issues
like that and then went to the second
level
the second level was when they're
interviewing the the digital patient
and you find things like it didn't
trigger when we thought it would or
in cases we will show you how we analyze
triggering
how it triggered too early or too late
in the scenarios if somebody had put in
a medical assistant
possible pneumonia in some cases it was
triggering off the keyword
and immediately coming up with the risk
calculator could move you into something
called the smart set very quickly
so it was too early triggering in other
cases people said it didn't trigger or
trigger too late the process
so there were a lot of sensitivities in
in doing this so as i mentioned each
phase identified different problems the
bpa labeling issue level one early late
triggering
so the idea was there was the prototype
prototype went to level one usability
testing with eight users in an office
didn't require lab
uh redesigned fixes were done the level
two simulation was done and that
focused more on the actual triggering
and the workflow of the guidelines
redesign fixes were done
and then it went to a limited live study
and a randomized control
and they were amazed i don't have the
stats there but the uptake of the
guidelines was much higher than they
usually were
because we've done this preparatory
process which normally isn't done
that's the alert this was for a
clinical prediction rule about strep
came up so a bit smaller but at least
it's written out there
if they wanted to see more it went into
the second component which was a
calculator risk calculator
it's interesting because when we did the
analysis we found people really liked
the calculator
some people were even going in the
system just to get the calculator
function
because they wanted to check the their
decision against the
latest guidelines and so if you fill
this
calculator out you get a strep score in
this case
we did strep and pneumonia uh this one
said the
score is between one to zero um if it
was a high risk
then you would also be asked you want to
go into
moves you along to the next level which
was the ordering set
so this is a good idea in that but it
was very we found some a lot of issues
that if we could tweak it we could get
the adoption better oh this was how we
coded um
usability problems some examples um
usability uh here is an example it's
becoming a lot of clicking and reading
and you want to do this thing quickly
especially for a lot of patients
visibility that was the code for the
issue that i just mentioned i just see
the bpa alert here normally i probably
wouldn't see it since i don't usually
look here
this one knew what it was but said it
wasn't very prominent
workflow issues i think it depends on
when you start using the tool because if
you use it right from the beginning
you can get distracted forget to go
through questions maybe
content uh that was an issue about i
think some recommendations about giving
soup
someone had some issue with um uh and
then usefulness i don't
uh like this it was the order set part
as much i realize this is all about
evidence-based medicine
but i just think there's more in a
clinical practice and this thing is
pushing in a direction
without taking account the full clinical
picture so in some cases it was because
it triggered too early and they were
saying i haven't even asked for an x-ray
and it's pushing me in this direction
so again the sort of sensitivities of
how to integrate
we looked at positive and negative
statements both in terms of coding
categories content navigation
readability understandability
um usability was mixed their half the
comments were positive half negative but
you expect on a usability test to get
some negative comments
we also looked at the different
components of of this
system if you will alerts calculators
smart set
documentation patient instructions and
what was interesting as i mentioned it
was our perception when we
we've watched them and we also coded
whenever they made a comment
that they did almost all the comments
about the calculator were extremely
positive
so you can use this approach to take
apart a tool that some people may like
and other people may complain about to
kind of get a
how to optimize it and what do people
actually like in the functions
uh this was just an example of we went
into looking at the triggering rates how
often were the guidelines triggered
and how often were they triggered and
then responded to
and this was just looking at how we
analyze workflow components
uh we said for example if they were
doing and on the screen doing diagnosis
and orders
that's time spent in the order diagnosis
and order field
uh ic pr cds was time spent
using one of the cds components alert
calculator smart set
uh one you know the the time spent doing
that uh time and progress notes and
our rvf was time and reason for visit so
i'll just show an example what you can
do
to analyze this we wanted to come up
with a way to analyze different
sequences
so this on this column is just saying
the first second third fourth fifth
thing sequence uh component access
and then we were able to characterize
some different styles this was called
early um a reason for visit access this
was late reason for visit
uh the reason for visit usually
triggered uh the guideline that's why
we're looking at it we're also looking
at cases where the guideline didn't get
triggered so just to give you an idea of
how we could look at the order uh so we
did a pie chart looking at different
time using the the system
and we could also relate that to the
comments about what people liked or
didn't like in terms of the
guideline so i've already mentioned in
phase one
the results were identification of
usability problems
uh main problems to do with usability
visibility of systems
status or visibility of a guideline on a
screen is an important category
uh workflow i've mentioned the issue of
workflow content navigation
and as i mentioned in phases two and
three uh there were different workflows
that emerged
uh including early and late triggering
of the rules
and uh we also looked at that in the
near live situation so adjustments were
made in all these
that was a one example um of one that
had all three levels where we found that
one level wasn't good enough to catch
everything a second example i have is of
um
another recent one i did this with the
colleague who's doing this phd from
denmark
uh rasmus rasmussen and we were looking
at
a bit of an experiment of is it useful
to record
hours of video so digital video of
people using a system and how can you
analyze that
so the project was one in denmark where
three hospitals were implementing
electronic whiteboard
and we installed the same screen
recording software on all the machines
hypercam
at three locations and there was about
166 hours of
data and we created log files that had a
lot of entries
2863 entries and it was for his phd so
he spent a lot of time sitting down
just analyzing it but he only had to do
it once and he was basically analyzing
it almost in real time
so but even given that we found that
once it was analyzed we could then
search the file and look up any type of
situation error or problem it was only
one time you had to do that
and these systems were already being put
in use
uh so there were many system related
usability problems that uh we were
looking at ones that reduced over time
and other ones didn't change over time
and some even seemed to get worse
over time the organization didn't seem
to adopt although we didn't control for
who came in
uh into the emergency departments there
might be new people coming in
that was the electronic whiteboard
screen
typical electronic whiteboard screen but
we had hours of continuous running data
on
on the live situation i'll just show
some examples so
even though this wasn't to think aloud
study you're able to go through and a
lot of it is blank space no one's
actually using the computer so after
that was my point about how it didn't
take so long to analyze later because
the first pass you got to watch
wait wait wait and then you'd mark when
something happened someone came on and
typed something in
here's an example of an efficiency
problem the user enters information in
both the free text field and search
fields when it only would have been
necessary to
information in the text field so we were
looking at even
things like that but there were also
amazingly enough system bugs
when entering free text information in
the next stop dialog box the system
deletes all information for the current
patient
and we saw that we were looking it over
we kept replaying it and it kept
happening
and no one had commented on it the thing
had been in use for months across three
hospitals so it was kind of scary
work patterns just an example a user
opens the location field selects the
team one tab selects an option clicks
okay
it removes the patient from the current
view of the whiteboard there was some
issue with not lack of visibility we
also are looking at number of steps
erasmus also did a paper using something
called the goms model where
he was looking at how to optimize the
number of steps and that all went back
to the developers because
he actually ended up working for that
company
so one of the ideas is combining the
approaches and
this is where we work with elizabeth and
how does usability relate to safety
and safety is important and we can do
error reporting systems but we've been
focusing a lot on
trying to say be proactive what can you
do before you release a system to try to
reduce errors
so in uh it's the mei yearbook of
medical informatics we kind of packaged
what i just said in this lecture
as perhaps we need to have multi-phase
evaluations prior to release
starting with a prerequisite laboratory
level one testing
moving to a clinical simulation and then
in situ or near live testing before
releasing systems
and i think that the paper by that we
did with lee ellis lee and
henry illustrated that with the
guidelines because we packaged them all
together and won
with better outcomes than we would just
doing one
um oh this other question comes up our
such approach is really low cost
if you know the usability area they'll
often say that the usability inspection
is low cost
that's the one where you don't watch
users because you're an analyst you just
pay one person to go through it
but no one had really done anything on
is the video analysis
easy to do or cheap and so we just did a
little experiment
on that we've done a few others on on
this the objective to determine the cost
effectiveness of what we call low-cost
in-situ clinical simulations
so what uh this was a master's thesis we
had him collect up all the costs of
doing it he was a consultant on a real
project
applied the low-cost approach uh for
disease management application
using only two case scenarios if you
could
you'll get more cost benefit if you can
do exhaustive testing of all kinds of
cases but this was only going to be done
in a few weeks so we only had two case
scenarios
of physicians entering data collect all
the data analysis costs quantify
benefits and calculate a cost-benefit
ratio
so this was actually the disease
management system tested
uh which actually didn't end up being
used in bc but it ended up in the yukon
um so he was developing the system and
also uh that was part of his thesis so
he had people come in eight users
charged had listed them for what they'd
actually cost for their time
and calculated the whole thing and then
there were fixes that had to be made
because they were actually going to
release it for real
and he had a table of charts of what
each fix would cost
so the total cost of conducting and
analyzing the data and the only reason
this was as high as eight thousand
dollars is because we included the
one-time cost of the laptop
but if you take that out the benefits
come up
uh rapid analysis only looking at two
scenarios we could have looked at 20 and
increased the cost benefit
detected a range of problems both
usability and safety issues
um and this and i mentioned this came up
more than one system we looked at
unfortunately
was that they they found that it was
going to be released and this testing
wouldn't have normally been done
but the body mass index calculator
didn't calculate properly
so when he defended his thesis remember
the external was from computer science
and said but that's not a usability
problem and it would have been caught
and he said no
uh that's not a usability problem but it
wouldn't have been caught because we
were
planning to release it so as another
layer
a a usability test or clinical
simulation
isn't just for usability or or clinical
workflow you'll catch other things that
weren't caught before
and safety issues were identified by the
medical expert potential costs of going
undetected
well that that's harder to estimate that
one but the most conservative he had for
the
things that that he would have to fix
because it was going to be released and
come back but he caught them
was that at least would have saved 15
000 at least the most conservative
it was much higher if we had spent more
time collecting data and we had no way
to actually estimate um
the cost of an error so we just looked
at what was the
us litigation cost for a major adverse
event
once and i don't know if that's correct
but it was around
it was a lot of money right so he said
if it prevented one if it had prevented
one case that was serious
you know say the body max indicator was
the wrong dosage calculation
could kill somebody then that was worth
that much
so there we go advantages of institute
testing this approach of taking it to
the real place
you take into account the context of the
system use the environmental context
we did another project in japan where
they were bringing was 2006 and they
were moving in the hospital to bar
coding
medication administration i think
elizabeth might have mentioned this one
and when you were looking at that study
if you tested the system in isolation
you wouldn't know how it interfaced with
the bar coding so
again the argument that if you wanna and
they called us in because they
we knew the cio and they said we want to
make sure it's going to be safe when we
release it
so they wanted just another check to do
it and again it was low cost so they let
us do it
geographical context of use rather than
a central usability lab if
bpa is a term used in one state but
you're in another state no one knows
what the term means
that's an issue and it gets even worse
for us because we're in canada and we're
often buying systems that come from the
us
so a lot of it has is really problematic
the
cultural issues in terms fidelity of
testing as i mentioned can be higher it
can be cheaper to conduct
and can be an adjunct to centralized
testing
some recent projects i'll just end with
that approach was applied to telehealth
again one of our we have students in our
program that are out there doing things
he was the director of the
bc health link which is the 911 calls to
nurses that have decision support
systems at the other end they get
thousands of calls per month uh he
applied the some of the methods
including um
not just the usability testing but the
inspection method
where you analyze as a analyst the
interface so he actually counted things
like he
came up with his own metric screen
turning how often do you have to
to change screens and doing that while
they're on going through the workflow
talking to a patient on the phone
and they were able to reduce and this
might not might sound like much
the call lengths by 30 seconds but
there's thousands of calls
and they also decrease the amount of
griping of people that were using the
system
so that was at uh any it was sort of a
cost benefit not in terms of dollars but
ftes the other one we've done the
usability approach
uh we we were doing a project elizabeth
ricky and and some others
colleagues on electronic medic planning
kit so we really tried to push into
there
that if you're going to electronic
medication reconciliation
that the proper analysis of the
usability and clinical simulations be
included and
i think also you did won the national
one for bar coding and pushed the same
idea
and uh just one mention of my first
venture into anything bioinformatics
related
uh now did usability of a clinical exam
analysis software
and we're also interested in talking to
bill in looking at integration of
genomic data and clinical practice from
a human factor's point of view
we haven't got to that part but we we
have done some comparisons
um this was the study in journal
biomedical informatics
we had surveys interviews and think
aloud protocol analysis
with the screen recording of two exome
sequence analysis software packages
uh subjects were 10 clinical geneticists
all that user screen actions were
recorded just like i've showed you
and uh because there were two systems we
were also able to counter balance and at
the end ask them which system they liked
and why and what features
the idea of this was also to come up
with recommendations for a design of new
tools
based on analyzing existing tools and so
what we did was have one system that was
actually a graphical user interface
tool uh and the other one was a command
line based tools we're looking at some
of the issues
uh implication results there were 193
usability issues detected
using the tools and the majority
concerned the layout and navigation
and interoperability uh pipelines of
data going in and out was an issue
and data standards that data standards
to do with this type of analysis
so implications for design they wanted a
richer filter functionality desired when
they were doing this analysis
like looking for mutant sequences uh the
scenarios were actually looking for
trying to detect uh mutant sequences uh
faster response time needed on one of
the tools
both tools elicited the idea of comments
about team support to
allow multiple clinicians to annotate or
review the data
and they also wanted more frequent
updates to support uh new input types
and tools
i don't know if you're familiar with
either of these the the first one was
uh varsity uh this is a
anyone familiar this is a also my
graphical interface tool uh on the left
side here is the view of the
variations and there's these pre-built
filters and this is the
on the right side the graphical feature
for user to custom design
their own queries and it was interesting
we were looking for implications so we
also looked at one that was apparently
used kgg sequence it's a command line
based system
and we were same idea we had them go
through
we also looked at how using both tools
which was more successful for finding
the answer to the case while they were
thinking aloud i think this one was but
it was frustrating for other reasons
being a graphical interface it tended to
be slower sometimes and sometimes
certain screens were
covered over other screens so it was the
same idea we just started applying
uh this to look at and that paper
actually comes up with some
recommendations for
design of new tools i thought i'd
mention that there's some
bioinformatics so we have worked on
bioinformatics just starting we'd really
like to look at human factors issues
in bioinformatics areas so if there any
possible collaborations there
i think that's a good one other
applications as i mentioned things like
mobile apps um
we're moving to doing some projects uh
we have a center for aging at the
university of victoria on
applications for the elderly and as i
said we continue working on electronic
health records decision support
and other types of applications this was
actually a screen from a system
called patsys that we use the approach
on back in the late 1990s that was the
the first web-based access by patients
to their own records over
over the web and now there's all kinds
of access uh you know my chart and epic
and
veterans affairs might help event so
it's changed a lot since since then
so our work since 2000 as i said is
trying to move to
predictive analysis to prevent errors
and improve usability
a range of testing methods saw a number
of papers if anyone's interested
we looked at improvement of software
improvement of the process of
development and the process of
integration of technology
uh this was interesting uh again as i
mentioned a lot of people will say what
can i do i have a vendor product
but there's a lot that can be done if
you track along the users in terms of
customization or
feedback if there's an issue with the
commercial system down the road we often
say what can we triage that and say
is there feedback into the system
development team for customization
potentially
or perhaps there's feedback to training
or perhaps the issue is so serious it
has to go back to the vendor which gets
to the soft
new approaches for software testing and
last but not least
is the whole idea of procurement if we
have so many problems with systems in
the first place
can we not have more rigorous analysis
of systems before they're selected
and what we proposed and this has been
done in a few places now is that
the procurements involved in the rfps in
test installs of systems in
lo representative hospitals
with uh usability type analysis and in
that case usability isn't just
testing isn't just for usability if you
do usability testing you'll also
determine functionality so in one case
there's a hospital in france that
did this and we had it in our paper as a
case study
they required all new systems to be test
installed and
accessed by real clinicians and they
could compare them and they found one
product was actually from germany and it
wasn't completely translated
so they picked the product from france
they actually took the report the
usability report
gave it back to the the vendor there was
a cycle there where they could actually
make changes
and then they improved the product and
the product became widely used in france
so it was a real success story
uh of doing uh the testing in the
procurement
so conclusions to ensure system
usability uh
the idea is we think there's a need to
disseminate uh these methods to
demystify them and say
it's not rocket science and it shouldn't
just be done in a centralized lab
and laboratory-based simulations are
obviously not enough
when you get systems that were
laboratory-based uh somewhere in
wisconsin or kansas city wherever and
you're using them in your real location
and you're having problems with them
then you really need a combination both
of centralized
testing and localized testing and this
is where we think the methods come in
this idea of layers of usability testing
and clinical simulation before release
if we want to make sure systems are safe
and my last point is
we teach this routinely talking to joan
this morning in our courses
uh within a few weeks we can have
students doing assignments on systems
they're using or other systems
and they'll be doing uh consultant level
reports using
two or three of those methods usability
inspection i usually start them with and
simple usability testing and many of
them have found really interesting
things about systems that
they've been using for years that needed
serious adjustments once they started
doing the projects
okay that's it
yeah so i'm just going to remind people
who ask
questions to hold down the button so
people can hear it
and um and then let me also remind
anyone who's listening
out there in cyberspace that if you
tweet with hashtag dmice comp
you'll be able to ask a question as well
um very nice talk
it's always good to get an update of
what you guys are doing
um i i particularly like the approach
uh because we use so much commercial
software now there's very little
um software that that gets developed at
least uh de novo in
in academic informatics settings um
how um how have the vendors uh responded
because there there's uh
um i'm trying to think of the right word
you know kind of the rumor on the street
you know that most vendors are somewhat
antagonistic
to um you know people telling them that
there's usability problems with their
software
even though they may have their own
usability labs in fact what says ask but
how have the vendors responded to these
sorts of approaches
well i i i had started working with
vendors but then
whenever we had changes like one of
those systems needed a map it was
released too they never would change it
so i've maybe been and
ended up working with regional health
authorities and public sector that's
buying systems
but still trying to work with vendors i
think and that's sort of
why in this presentation i kind of
mentioned the need for local testing
because
i think there's been a bit of a
communication gap when we've talked to
some vendors they've said we know all
about this and we do it we do it
routinely at the test host beta test
hospital in some city
and then when you look at it it's
puzzling because you go but i've
received this system i'm in another city
and it's not even in the same country
and it's not working properly or not
working to fit our workflow
so that's where we sort of want to to
push the theme of you
the vendors should do as rigorous
testing as they can uh
but it's also going to be the
responsibility of local sites uh because
the vendors won't be doing that
to do their testing to feed back to them
but we found a bit of a
maybe a miscommunication with some
vendor organizations that have felt that
this is being taken care of and then you
get the discrepancy from the end users
and i will note even in countries with
um a
colleague of mine uh has done uh uh
she does um uh questionnaires to fourth
out all the all the
all the physicians in finland and
they're 100 use of emrs they have to use
them
but her questionnaire is about usability
vivian not vivian but anyways johanna
capio
and and there's a lot of dissatisfaction
with the systems out there and they
actually noted on the questionnaire
they would like to be more involved by
providing feedback
to the vendors but they don't feel
they're in the loop in
ontario canada there's a program that
lets you pay
a government pays for systems you buy uh
they have started creating uh
sites like rate my emr like rate my
professors so
that's kind of also another move towards
that and i've heard in the united states
there would be more sharing of
information about vendor products
um but it has been a an issue uh
to to get back to working with vendors
so i think we
i've personally been working a lot with
organizations that are hospitals
they're on the line they want to make
sure it's safe or it's a region that's a
public
region and they want to spend money to
buy system make sure they get the right
system
so yeah the long answer it's it's that's
that's that's a real issue
i think it's a knowledge translation and
communication issue
yeah thank you for the talk um what
would you say to our human factors
colleagues from engineering backgrounds
who keep asking
why is this so hard um
it's uh they're probably used to working
in other areas i mean
you could compare they've done very well
in aerospace but there's a whole
mechanisms there and processes
a lot of the i also teach systems
analysis and design and i taught
it generally but i'm trying to adapt it
to healthcare and a lot of the
methods and processes for developing
systems uh
are using syst approaches that would be
used for business applications in
healthcare
which is a safety critical area so it's
it's sort of a mismatch in the design of
the systems um
and not as a dig dig to engineers but
i've often seen engineering labs do
these type of studies and they focused
on
you know the optimal screen layout which
is why the first example i gave it was
also about usefulness
so they may be more worried in other
areas about how to optimally lay the
information out whereas this one's got
the
clinical content is it a value the
subtleties of how even organized
information might change how you ask
questions
which therefore changes your direction
of reasoning it's just such
uh so much harder than any other area
yes i was intrigued by the conclusion
that you made
that users perceptions don't always
agree with the actions captured in video
and
do you have any recommendations for
reconciling the two
sources of data and where does the truth
lie
uh yeah that's a good question and i
think one of the issues is time lag
people forget things although those
questionnaires were given after
with that example i'd say one of the
problems was uh
why you need to look for emergent impact
or system
of systems is because on a questionnaire
we presuppose what we're looking for
something new came up called screen
driven behavior we didn't think about
um so that's that's an issue of
of uh what was the question again about
how do you reconcile video data compared
to questionnaire data and
especially when they don't agree yes
when when we didn't do
questionnaires and we just had an
interview going it was actually quite
close because we
usually just use five five or six
prompts like you just did the task tell
me did you have any problems and we
match them
uh the questionnaires again because they
they have presupposed categories they're
not free-flowing
and even when you have a text box for
them to enter something
they may not enter it or in some cases
i've had them filling out very good and
then handing it to me i want to
encourage you thinking i'm the developer
so we get more from a semi-structured
interview probing what they're doing
and regarding that another interesting
comparison is that
as doing those interviews right after
doing a series of tasks
versus a focus group an issue with focus
groups that are often very useful and we
still do them
is that the focus group the use of the
system and the focus group might be some
difference in time
and time elapsing so in some of the
studies we did where the users were able
to tell us right after using a
medication administration system
this won't work during an emergency that
discussion wouldn't come up in a focus
group so in focus groups we tended to
also bring in
the artifacts and have them work through
it so it's more immediate rather than
trying to recall what you did a long
time ago
sort of like medications
yeah well it's self-report it if it's
about the experience about the usability
what we found
like that kind of you know i'm going
through navigation problem
questionnaires we're not so useful for
that although sometimes they have been
useful there was one example
on a large um uh project in canada it
was the canadian defense they sent out
questionnaires to everybody
and everyone came back the system was
too slow on the questionnaire
but then they went to the company
developed the system and the company
said oh it must be your international
network
so then we did a qualitative study and
found out why it was too slow what part
of the system
so sometimes the questionnaires can
trigger something and we often use them
the other way we use questionnaires i
didn't get into something called the vu
lab or virtual usability lab where we
track
people using systems live for using
guidelines and things
and or a new system over time and a
questionnaire that we found useful was
saying
uh that every few months we had a
questionnaire how's your
relation with your provider going on a
one-to-five scale that was a really
useful use of a questionnaire
item and we could disperse it to
thousands of people however for the kind
of studies we were doing where we wanted
to know what to change in the user
interface
a questionnaire often even if they wrote
something was
highly on unusable it doesn't give you
where
what to change
it could yeah
yeah and then that would warrant further
investigation
yeah and the other one as i mentioned uh
uh the studies and this is a
we did a paper in uh this last year's
medical
yearbook of medical informatics because
the theme was on big data so we're going
what's big data related to this
there are some large scale usability
studies that are questionnaire based so
the one in finland what she did was send
a very nice questionnaire out to every
physician in finland
she even had them compare the government
recommended products
and that provided a lot of really useful
information um but now that group is
actually going back and looking at some
of the usability issues so exactly like
you said it
was a triggering or the example i gave
of everyone in the defense department
encounters saying this system is too
slow but then without further
investigation
there was no conclusion no rectification
yes you know it may be an issue of
asking the right question because you
asked the question is this
a system that usable people say yes it's
very usable but
you know the fundamental question would
you ever use this in clinical practice
in the
answer maybe no i'd never use it because
i you know i never see this kind of
patient or i never
deal with this problem in this way so it
may be
an issue the type of the way the
question is yeah
because they could say maybe i'm
answering it is it usable in this
session
uh as in the case of the one i gave
where
they said they could do the task but
when they're with the patient during an
interview they said
i have problems with it yeah yeah
exactly yeah
okay thanks